je parlerai enfin de la censure évoquée
par l'ancien ministre lui-même plus d'un
professeur sur deux ça vousou sêt déjà
autant censuré enquête Ifop décembre
2022 pour reprendre ses propos il serait
y avoir d'omerta dans l'éducation
nationale et je suis intraitable à ce
sujet qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
concrètement le ministère
sanctionnerait-il celui qui n'applique
pas le programme mais quel est le
soutien de l'institution quand un
professeur relève le défi d'assurer son
programme il faut bien reconnaître que
défendre les valeurs républicaines est
bel et bien une prise de risque la
menace de se prendre Samuel pati est
devenue unearme de toute censure
islamique la circulaire de l'éducation
nationale intitulé plan laïcité dans les
écoles et établissements scolaires du 9
novembre 2022 tente d'apporter une
réponse le premier volet consiste à
sanctionner systématiquement et de façon
graduée le comportement des élèves
portant atteinte à la laïcité lorsqu'il
persistent après une phase de dialogue
c'est mal connaître ces jeunes de penser
qu'un rappel à l'ordre à la loi sert à
quelque chose ce qui est perçu comme une
sanction pour éducation nationale est
perçu tout au plus comme une humiliation
aux yeux de cette jeunesse qui n'accorde
aucun crédit à l'autorité ces sanctions
qui ne débouchent sur rien développent
un sentiment d'impunité et entraînent
récidive ou vengeance on traite les
symptômes sans traiter le mal le
problème est l'absence générale
d'autorité envers cette jeunesse qui n'a
plus de limite et qui donc ni ne peut ni
ne veut faire société l'école ne peut
pas lier la carence de figure
représentant l'autorité auprès de ses
jeunes mais il faut lui rendre celle qui
lui est propre pour cela il faut que
l'institution endosse les rôles qui lui
incombent c'est-à-dire sa capacité à
prendre sous sa responsabilité les
sujets les plus sensible il faut
également que cette même institution
réponde du traitement erroné et de la
non protection qui en a découlé dans le
dossier de mon frère sinon pourquoi les
enseignants prendrai-ils le risque de
défendre les valeurs républicaines s'ils
ne sont pas assurés d'être protégés et
ainsi rassurés il faut restaurer une
république au comportement ferme sur ces
principes exemplaires et responsables al
on pourra parler d'autorité légitime et
ainsi obtenir l'adhésion par respect et
non par soumission en infantilisant ou
en manipulant le sentiment de
peur perdre l'école ce n'est pas perdre
une bataille ni offrir une prise de
guerre à
l'adversaire c'est perdre la guerre